hello
and thanks so much for joining for this
brief presentation
on our experiences with the epi lamp
program
and specifically how we have adapted
leadership and management training for
national immunization teams
in the time in the context of covert 19.
my name is erica lenander
i direct a group out of yale called the
global health leadership initiative
and i'm joined in this experience by my
colleagues in our partner organizations
as part of the epi lamp consortium
including representatives from the
university of global health equity in
rwanda
the university of yonde and cameroon
gavi
path and and of course our students and
alumni
in the program so the reason that um
that i want to talk with you about the
epilap experience and our adaptations in
the context of covid
is that we know that leadership and
management are essential in the covert
response
so in times of crises we really need
national immunization teams
to be able to come together solve
problems and move forward in a
coordinated national response
and yet at the same time we see
investments
in routine health system strengthening
being diverted
into more acute covent response and
our old models of training for
leadership and management just aren't
viable
in the context of covid given
restrictions on travel and convening
and so the question becomes how can we
uh
provide support for leadership and
management in this new context
so just to provide a little bit of
background on what the epilap
program is epilimp is a nine-month
certificate
program for national immunization teams
in gothi eligible countries
so we have participants come together as
teams
to build their management and leadership
capacity in the six areas
shown on the poster there strategic
problem solving leading effective teams
political engagement human resource
management financial management and
supply chain management
we've been delivering the program since
2018 we're now
offering our the program for cohorts
four and
five uh so we've reached 54 alumni and
49
current delegates across 27 gabi
eligible countries
in french and english speaking africa
and asia
obviously like most of us we were forced
to adapt the program
in the context of covet 19 and i want to
tell you a little bit about how we've
done that
and our results to date so if you zip
over to the
right hand side of the poster you see we
used two methods for adaptation
the first thing we did is we worked with
each participating country
to undergo a structured risk assessment
to understand
how were they working remotely were they
working remotely how was it going
any lessons learned there what was their
internet internet connectivity and cost
like
um would they be able to participate in
the program given competing priorities
so what would the program have to look
like to be on demand and flexible um
how might they like to collaborate we
combined that country-specific risk
assessment
with a review of the literature the
peer-reviewed literature and the gray
literature
around best practices for online
education for
professionals and as a result of those
two inputs the country-specific
assessment
and then the um kind of systematic
review of best practices
we came up with five adaptations to the
epilamp experience
that i want to talk with you about the
first is that we came up with
um with a framework we came up with a
way of approaching
um the creation of a professional
learning community
that was evidence-based so we could have
confidence and our participants could
have confidence
that we were attending to all the
different parts of
curricular approaches that would be
needed for them to be successful
we also shifted away from in-person
convenings and instead moved to
increase investment in small group
facilitation online
meaning lots of breakout rooms
investment in facilitators and those
breakout rooms that could use
miro and other knowledge capture tools
to make sure that these sessions were
really
active and engaging we updated the
curriculum with covet specific
applications so still teaching the real
essentials of management and leadership
but making sure that they were always
focused on the practical challenges
that teams were facing in the context of
the coveted response
we broadened our communication channels
to include slack
and whatsapp so that we're able to reach
delegates to reach participants
on multiple channels throughout the day
throughout the week throughout the
program
and finally we found mechanisms to get
participants cash
for mobile access so across our
participating countries
we found that actually the internet was
okay it was just expensive
and so we needed if we wanted
participants to come online
turn on their videos participate
actively we needed to make sure
that they had the financial compensation
to to buy that airtime
and turn their videos on we're just over
halfway through the program now through
cohorts four and five
with this new model and i want to share
a little bit about results today
first of all as you see in that middle
panel there we're having 88
participation in our bi-weekly live
sessions
that means that despite their busy
schedules despite
the challenges of internet connectivity
participants are coming
online and participating we think this
is because the
sessions are highly interactive because
the content is relevant and because
they're learning from
each other in those sessions we've also
seen that the demand for coaching we
provide coaching
to each one of the teams and the demand
for those coaching sessions
is twice what it has been in past
cohorts
so again even though these participants
are very busy
in the context of covid we're seeing
that they actually want more coaching
um again highlighting the relevance of
the program
and because of this new model where
things are better integrated
and we're being much more responsive
we're seeing better progress on their
breakthrough projects
um now halfway through the program
compared to prior cohorts
so this integrated virtual model of
delivery
is actually delivering better results
than the old model of bringing
participants together
for periodic in-person trainings
so what does this mean what do we take
from this experience first of all
national immunization professionals are
demanding leadership support
despite the competing challenges
associated with the cove
with cobia 19. so we thought they'd be
too busy we thought they'd be distracted
but instead they're telling us no
we need leadership support now do
not cancel this thing um the second
implication that we're seeing
is that through systematic adaptation
using the methods that i've described
earlier
virtual models can be accessible
engaging and responsive
so the virtual stuff can work as long as
you go about it
systematically and based on evidence and
lastly i think we're seeing from our
participants
a call for leadership development to
remain
part an integral part of national and
global response and recovery
thanks for taking the time to listen and
learn a little bit more about the epilip
program if you want to learn even more
scan the qr code up in the top left
corner
that will take you to a website that
will give you a little bit more
background on the program
as well as some mobile friendly content
so you don't have to squint
at this tiny little pdf poster thanks
again